start the day by sipping a cup of maple
bacon coffee and capturing the world
from your dog's point of view with fetch
the GoPro dog harness but first please
put on your pants shirt because it's
episode 45 of Lou let your lunch travel
slimly and safely with the food skin
flexible lunchbox that compactly keeps
food fresh and prevents me from getting
mangled purchase something to pig out on
using funds from a scented Belgian
waffle coin purse or curb the cash just
carry cards with the decadent minimalist
one a wallet made out of a single piece
of aluminum that securely carries up to
eight identification or credit cards
which you'll probably need to pay for
this ferrari carbon fiber chess set
finger hands feed your feet desert with
shoe bakery fancy confectionary Footwear
from ice cream flats to pink cake wedges
if those don't float your boat just
float tiny objects with sound the
ultrasonic levitation machine is
designed to allow people to experiment
with anti-gravity fields created by
sound
so maybe we can someday have a
hoverboard visualize sound with light
show fountain speakers that are
compatible with all USB friendly music
devices and time your tunes with a light
and water show using four multi colored
LEDs change the color of your
cleanliness by installing glass shower
tiles that feature distinct designs
depending on the temperature they appear
black at room temperature and color
variations range from Northern Lights to
tie-dye try to chew on chemistry by
making your own chewing gum adult
supervision recommended being an adult
is required when enjoying the beer
briefcase but to stay hydrated in the
wild there's the katadyn pocket water
filter built for a lifetime of use
thanks to a silver impregnated ceramic
filter use revive a phone to bring your
phone back from a watery death pour the
solution into the pouch power down your
phone put it in there for seven minutes
and it removes destructive mineral
residue on the motherboard
resurrecting your water damaged mobile
then charge it with Sun power with the
port's solar charger that has an
integrated sux
cup allowing it to stick to any window
stick to swear words if you want to win
uh f asterisk asterisk acacia nary the
adults-only dirty word game described as
cards against humanity' meets
Scattergories technology meets tailoring
with the M tailor app that lets you
customize every aspect of your shirt
from fabric and color to cuff style and
then uses your mobile devices camera to
measure you twenty percent more
accurately than a professional tailor
giving you perfect fitting custom shirts
from the comfort of your jellyfish chair
which you can sit back on and relax
while you stare at your six million
digits of pi poster finally fly your
giant 50-foot long solar balloon in
preparation for your world view balloon
voyage to the edge of space which for
only seventy five thousand dollars per
passenger will float you a hundred
thousand feet from the ground you don't
want to fall from that height and you
just might reach terminal velocity and
as always thanks for watching